the nationwide effort to fight racism is
shedding new light on the financial
imbalances between races in this country
listen to these numbers just 44 percent
of black Americans owned their home that
they live in and that's compared to more
than 73 percent of white Americans the
economic imbalance also extends into the
banking industry CBS News special
correspondent that's Alex Wagner joins
us now Alex good to see you good morning
to you what role did the banks play in
this huge racial wealth gap
yeah Gail the numbers are pretty stark
when you look at lending to minorities
from big banks versus black owned
financial institutions as you know
homeownership skews heavily towards
white Americans and owning a home is
considered among the best ways to build
wealth and home ownership almost always
starts with alone the mortgage this is
the home to that purchase with the hope
mortgage loan ten years ago it was
unclear if 31 year old Brittany Williams
would ever become a homeowner the credit
wasn't as good as it could be because of
some things I did in high school with
this management credit that point I
didn't have any idea of how I could make
it better with few resources and poor
credit the big banks didn't seem
interested in helping her build a solid
financial foundation she wasn't alone
African Americans remain underserved by
America's largest financial institutions
nearly half of all black Americans
either have no bank or are underbanked
meaning they lack access to financial
services like credit cards and loans
that's almost double the rate of the
country as a whole
so Williams went elsewhere hope credit
union a black-owned financial
institution I feel like they would give
me a better understanding of what which
path I should be going down and the
branch manager she instantly was telling
me about a certain loan
could help me reestablish my credit with
that help Williams fixed her credit at
26 she qualified for a home mortgage and
I was able to finance that right phone
black on banks like Hope can play a
critical role in building
african-american financial security we
have to look at the context in the
reality of deep racial wealth inequality
racial economic inequality that's been
part of this country since its founding
when you have very little wealth of your
own media wealth from blacks made about
thirty six hundred dollars it's that
much harder to get alone because you
know you have to have some type of
savings right Diedrich Asante mohamed is
with the national community reinvestment
coalition banks have played a role that
most of society has played a reflected
society and a society that was not
looking forward to bring african
americans in as part of their practices
their inclusion so african-americans
didn't feel that banks were something to
serve them in the last decade alone
three major national banks have paid
hundreds of millions in federal
settlements for alleged racial
discrimination something that's been
part of the American lending system for
nearly a century through a practice
called redlining loans were denied in
largely black neighborhoods the courts
have since deemed it illegal to counter
discriminatory practices black owned
banks were born we really are the
catalyst for our communities Cynthia day
president and CEO of citizens Trust says
black owned banks like hers helped break
a cycle of poverty we can get you into
the system and then we can let you
elevate from product to product and get
you into mainstream banking relationship
so we go from credit builders to wealth
builders today at black owned banks 33%
of mortgage loans go to African
Americans versus less than three percent
at banks that are not black owned it's
that kind of inequality that's helped
fuel protests across the country
and just as white Americans joined black
Americans on the streets joining a black
owned bank can be an important act of
unity your money can count in ways that
I think a lot of people haven't even
considered absolutely you know you can
support addressing racial inequality
without solely being on the streets
protest you need to incorporate that in
your everyday life how you spend your
everyday dollars to your everyday
investments that will help create the
long-term change that we need so
desperately in this country so on
Tuesday Netflix announced a ten million
dollar investment in Hope Credit Union
the bank in that story which hope says
they will use to fund more than 2,500
entrepreneurs homebuyers and consumers
of color over the next two years Tony
it's powerful stuff these black owned
banks can help counter discrimination in
the present but there is that historical
context that long history and there may
be something more that needs to be done
to address that there was a great piece
over the weekend by Nicole Hannah Jones
who's been at our table about the need
for reparations that's another R word
that a lot of people don't want to talk
about alright Alex thank you very much